[Música]
[Aplausos]
los próximos 10 minutos alrededor de 75
personas están experimentando por
primera vez lo que se le llama amor a
primera vista sentimiento que yo
experimenté la primera vez cuando tenía
18 años y pisé el museo tamayo de arte
contemporáneo en la ciudad de mexico y
encontrarme ahí en la galería principal
rodeada de luz natural y un ambiente
natural
me hizo provocar me un sentimiento que
en ese momento no supe explicar
en ese momento quedó tan grabado en mi
memoria que posteriormente me hizo
dedicarme a lo que ahora me dedico y
probablemente ahí también nació mi
incontrolable ganas de conocer el mundo
y todos los museos del mundo puede ser
que hoy entre el público haya muchas
personas que no tienen ningún interés en
arquitectura algunas tienen cierto
interés ya otros les da totalmente lo
mismo pero déjenme decirles que la
arquitectura
y marcó y modificó el comportamiento de
todos ustedes y los hizo ser quién son
esto se debe a que la arquitectura
modifica el comportamiento de las
personas pasamos un 90% de nuestras
vidas dentro de espacios interiores y la
calidad de esto se manifiesta en cómo
beneficiamos o perjudicamos nuestra
salud y nuestra calidad de vida
este silencio que acabo de provocar en
ustedes
me hizo sentirme de la misma forma
ya que me quedé a tónica atónita también
cuando entré al coliseo romano en roma
y la luz que entró por encima realmente
me hizo darme cuenta de que la luz es un
elemento muy natural que debe estar
presente en todos los espacios
nosotros como arquitectos y diseñadores
somos los responsables de crear este
tipo de ambiente y las repercusiones en
la salud mental en las personas las
tenemos nosotros
hay un dicho muy famoso que dice
a todos nos rompen el corazón alguna vez
en la vida por primera vez y esto nos
sucede a todos pero de
y ahora arriba del transporte público
arriba de un mercedes benz pues
preferiríamos llorar arriba de un auto
de lujo no esto suena a chiste pero qué
pasaría si justo te acaban de romper el
corazón y además tienes que compartir tu
habitación de dos por dos con tus dos
hermanos en este momento lo único que
quieres es llorar y sacar todo ese
sentimiento que traes adentro pero no
puedes porque probablemente vas a
despertar a tus dos hermanos y al vecino
el cual solamente lo separa una pared el
no sacar esta emoción va a ser que te
vuelvas una persona resentida una
persona que probablemente pueda ser
violenta en un futuro
como nosotros como arquitectos y
diseñadores somos rep bueno los
iniciadores de este tipo de sentimientos
y esto lo podemos ver no solamente en la
vivienda en la vivienda pues sin la
vivienda comercial ya que cada vez son
más
los distintos
y departamentos en grandes ciudades con
ridículas dimensiones de dimensiones y
muchos de estos departamentos son
compartidos entre dos o tres personas
lo que hace también que los espacios no
inciten a las personas se realizan las
actividades en ellos
digo a quien le darían ganas de cocinar
en una cocina super pequeña sin
iluminación que ni siquiera te permite
realizar los movimientos necesarios para
para cocinar y probablemente esta sea
una de las razones por las cuales hoy en
día solo sabemos hacer cereal con leche
y sopas instantáneas con agua
las repercusiones en la salud mental
debido al dimensionamiento de los
espacios nos encontramos presentes en
muchos lugares pero nosotros somos los
que no a veces no alcanzamos a
dimensionar que con estas medidas
estamos repercutiendo
la conducta de las personas y que
exponemos a la gente a situaciones de
ira de estrés de violencia y algunos
casos de abuso
y esto también ocurre en los espacios
destinados a oficinas
ya que muy comúnmente los trabajadores
se ven perjudicados en como rinden en a
la hora de trabajar las lugares de
oficina muchas veces los los empleados
se ven
perjudicados en sus actividades
cotidianas debido a que hace falta
espacios destinados a la recreación que
nos permitan distraerse porque es bien
conocido que es necesario dejar un poco
pues nuestro trabajo distraernos para
luego volver y desempeñar lo de una
mejor manera
a empresas como google facebook apple
volaris entre otras
saben que para que los empleados sean
más productivos empiecen a trabajar
mejor y obtengan a espacios
donde las personas puedan colaborar
pues han implementado este tipo de
soluciones
esta es una de las oficinas de google
digo a quién no le gustaría trabajar en
un lugar así
con espacios que permiten el trabajo en
equipo la integración de plantas hasta
puedes llevar a tu perro digo
a quien no le gustaría no de modo que es
necesario que empezamos a replicar este
este tipo de espacios porque actualmente
muchos corporativos y oficinas solo se
encargan de meter al mayor número de
personas dentro de una oficina mal
iluminada sin plantas interiores y todo
todo lo quieren resolver con aire
acondicionado
hace un año tuve la oportunidad de
visitar tokio con mi mejor amigo
fuimos del otro lado del mundo a ver
como los japoneses no solo son pioneros
en innovación y tecnología sino en la
integración de los elementos naturales
en la arquitectura
tokio cuenta con más de 80 parques
urbanos un parque nacional y más de 7000
parques municipales realmente fue
increíble poder observar que cientos de
personas entre locales y visitantes
acudían a estos parques a realizar
actividades como caminar pasear a su
perro y llevaban a los niños a
reconectar con la naturaleza que eso hoy
en día se ha perdido y en la
arquitectura ni se diga tuvimos la
oportunidad de subir a una edificación
en un piso número 52 y aún estando a esa
altura encontramos que había árboles
plantas y un diseño minimalista que
realmente hizo algo mágico que fue crear
esa conexión entre usuario arquitectura
y experiencia natural
desgraciadamente en latinoamérica este
tipo de conexión se ha ido perdiendo ya
que cada vez son menos los espacios
destinados a parques y áreas verdes
nuestras únicas opciones en mexico
domínguez como se dice es ir a los
centros comerciales decir por una nieve
ir a comer algo gastar pero qué pasa con
las personas que no tienen estos
recursos
qué pasa si no tengo el dinero a dónde
acuden estas personas
necesitamos recuperar espacios
destinados a realizar actividades al
aire libre
que nos quiten esa carga de estrés que a
veces llevamos por nuestras actividades
diarias o por situaciones de la vida
cotidiana necesitamos espacios que nos
inspiren
nos hagan ser creativos que nos hagan
ser personas más humanas
es necesario que empecemos a crear las
ciudades que merecemos pensadas para los
usuarios para sus necesidades y para su
salud mental que por ende va a
repercutir en que eleve su calidad de
vida
pero es tarea de todos nosotros a que
esto suceda
ya que muchas veces uno se enfrenta a
personas de mentes cerradas
con opiniones como no eso no funciona
eso no es posible
y eso no deja dinero hay muchas
respuestas negativas y personalmente
pues a veces si afectan a uno pues que
nos digan este tipo de cosas pero
personalmente considero que están en
nosotros y en ustedes aceptar este nuevo
tipo de ideas para que la calidad de la
vida de todos nosotros mejore
y yo estoy totalmente convencida de que
los espacios que integran elementos
naturales un correcto dimensionamiento y
una conexión repercuten de manera
positiva en la salud de las personas y
por ende a mejorar su calidad de vida
un ejemplo de ello es una de mis
propuestas
en las cual
y ese diseño se rediseñó perdón a
vivienda a partir de un jardín interior
este espacio lo que hace es que además
brinda luz natural a las áreas aledañas
ha creado que los niños salgan a jugar
en sus triciclos y los padres salgan a
leer en su nuevo espacio favorito
no sólo funciona estéticamente sino que
este lugar ha permitido que las familias
salgan convivan se reúnan
y algo muy interesante fue también que
pro hizo que la gente adquirirá el
hábito de la lectura que pues es algo
que necesitamos hoy en día también
dentro de este proyecto también
a los usuarios empiezan empezaron perdón
a descansar de una mejor forma y esto es
debido a que en la vivienda se hizo una
integración de plantas purificadoras
en el ambiente que hacen que las
personas descansen de una mejor forma
después al día siguiente vayan con toda
la actitud a trabajar ya desarrollar sus
actividades
de modo que es importante que se rompa
con el paradigma de cómo es que se debe
proyectar la arquitectura y empecemos a
apostarle a estos espacios porque
necesitamos espacios donde las personas
crezcan mejor que nos hagan mejores
personas mejores hijos mejores padres y
mejores redes sociales una frase muy
importante que largarán arquitecto
mexicano luis barragán alguna vez dijo y
vale la pena mencionarlo
fue creo en una arquitectura emocional
aquella que no sólo resuelve los
problemas físicos sino que crea además
belleza y emoción esa esa esa
arquitectura gracias
[Aplausos]